[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here first of all
welcome to techtober
and i've been wearing this red apple
watch series 6 every day since the
impressions video now so been living
with it i've worked out with it i've
slept with it on
pretty much everything so this is the
full review oh and by the way if you're
wondering like hey what about the video
about this other thing or where's your
video on x or insert review here
there's a lot going on right now in the
tech world that's why we named them
october and september so we're catching
up to a lot of it expect a lot of videos
in october but okay so summary with this
watch is
there's really not a whole ton of
massively new stuff as you already knew
like okay some slightly brighter always
on display
cool slightly faster charging
cool uh and also a slightly new sensor
with the blood oxygen but a lot of the
stuff that makes the apple watch
the apple watch and so good is of course
in the software watchos that's gonna
make its way to other apple watches but
i think one of the biggest mistakes we
make in the tech world
so often in these mature categories is
comparing the new thing to last year's
thing
when most people buying the new thing
aren't upgrading from last year's thing
that's actually a pretty rare use case
most people have three four-year-old
plus versions that are aging by the time
they upgrade to this one so yeah
surprise if you already have an apple
watch series 4 or 5
you don't need to upgrade but if you
don't have an apple watch yet well this
is the most
complete
ecosystem
bait yet so let's just start with the
headlighting new feature which is
actually the blood oxygen sensor uh it's
not actually the first smartwatch to add
this but they did add it now to the
apple watch and well it probably
shouldn't be your reason to buy this
watch now i mean for what it's worth
i've been getting pretty decent accurate
measurements as far as i can tell you
get it pretty snug slide it down your
wrist near your hand and sit still for a
few seconds anything in the upper 90s is
normal and i've i've gotten like 98 to
100 every time i try it sitting down
great but if for some reason i stood up
or moved around a little bit or for
whatever reason i didn't get 98 and i
got 88 for some reason which would be a
concerning actual measurement
i wouldn't really be freaking out at all
because lots of people have gotten very
inaccurate measurements or just had
problems getting a good reliable measure
at all but for a little background a
dedicated blood oxygen sensor
is normally worn on your fingertip just
like that i actually learned this while
i was working with david blaine on the
ascension project uh he needed one to be
really accurate to actually tell if he
was hypoxic or not which would be
dangerous
but you clamp it to your finger and it
just measures the blood oxygen
saturation by shining a light through
your fingertip and then reading it on
the other side so it's going through
your finger now the apple watch is
attempting to get the same reading but
obviously in a non-ideal place on the
back of your wrist so it's shining into
your wrist but obviously can't read from
the other side so it's trying to read
from the reflections
and most blood oxygen sensors don't read
this way for a reason it's just much
more difficult to get an accurate
reliable reading from this spot on your
body now actually as dave 2d points out
in his video you can actually take the
apple watch off and put it on your
fingertip to get much more consistent
readings but yeah if you're doing all
that and you care that much about
accurate blood oxygen readings you
should just grab a 25 pulse oximeter
from amazon and it will be way more
accurate than any smart watch so yeah
this is much more just like a casual
extra sensor to give you some new
readings in the health app if you want
to gamify it and track it uh so if you
go for hikes and stuff then cool you get
to see oh my blood oxygen's 94 instead
of 100
but you shouldn't be taking it to the
doctor um speaking of extra readings in
the health app sleep mode so there's
sleep tracking built into the apple
watch now it is actually a watch os 7
feature again so it's not like it's
exclusive to the series six but hey i
tested it like i said i've been wearing
it every day i've been sleeping in the
apple watch because i guess that's the
apple effect getting people to try
things
so when you're about to go to sleep you
swipe up control center hit that little
bedtime icon and the screen goes black
and it starts sleep tracking and really
what i found is it doesn't track that
much hardcore information like basically
it's whether it thinks you're asleep or
not heart rate once in a while
trends up and down things like that
pretty casual but nothing really
groundbreaking and people who already
have been using third party apple watch
apps to track sleep already know way
more about their sleep than this will
tell you but like i said it's just one
more thing that's plugging into the
health app and giving you a pretty good
basic look at what's going on here so
okay it works and that's great and
everything but you know what the best
part is you know the best part of
wearing an apple watch to sleep
actually is
it's the alarm 100 it's the alarm it
just taps you awake just with a little
haptic motor no sound or anything
and that's been massively underrated i
really don't like wearing a thing like
this to sleep but the fact that it just
taps me awake and i never have an actual
alarm sound
has been a pretty sweet but also apple i
noticed it adds standing hours while i'm
asleep
so i wake up every day with like two to
four standing hours which is kind of odd
because
i don't know about you but i sleep lying
down but the charging question the
charging question is interesting now
because if you wear the watch all day
and then you wear it to sleep when do
you charge the thing it does have
slightly faster 90 minute zero to 100
charging but when do you actually get it
on the charger for me i found two times
during the day and neither of them are a
full charge but the first one is like
right when i like go shower at night but
after a workout or something i'll pop it
on the charger and that'll juice it up
enough to last through the night and
then when i wake up in the morning so it
taps me awake and i just take it off and
put it on the charger and go through my
morning routine so it's just sitting on
the charger juicing up for the day so it
never actually gets to 100 i'm just kind
of always bouncing between 20 and 85
which is actually better for battery
health on the watch
and yeah i never got it to die in a day
again so battery life on the watch is
still good it's still about what it's
been for series four and five and i also
do have the always-on display going to
me the real best feature of the apple
watch series 6 is just the new s6 chip
inside like that's what's giving you the
great efficiency to last all day that's
what's giving you the brighter always on
display uh if you disable the oezon
display you'll probably get even better
battery life and then it's enabling the
faster charging that chip is giving you
the great performance through watchos 7
which now has faster snappier animations
throughout the whole thing which is
great
oh and also the hand washing detection
in watchos 7 is kind of hilarious like
it'll pick up that yes i am washing my
hands through the microphone and the
movement it's sensing and then it'll
start some countdown timer based on when
it thinks you started and if you get to
the end of the 20 seconds great
little soapy thumbs up thing but if you
don't get to the end of the 20 seconds
it just kind of quietly disappears
like reminding you to do it better next
time the shame but yeah all this stuff
pretty minor i think the biggest
literally the biggest change most people
notice with this new watch is the colors
which by the way i'm going to be
switching back to my black series 5
because i it does look cool sometimes
but i don't need a red watch every
single day but also the other new thing
they made alongside the new watch is the
new
solo loop bands and they are a great
idea i love the simplicity of just
stretching a band to put it on no velcro
or magnets or buckles or anything you
just put it on get your size right which
can be a little finicky but get it snug
and it's super clean the only weird
thing is they seem to fit the watch a
little bit worse than all the other
bands like see how it doesn't go quite
all the way to the edge of the watch and
you can kind of see some of the metal
inside instead of it sitting flush with
the red of this watch kind of weird if
you find that important i personally
don't but it's worth noting so you can
see it here but you know these are 50 to
100 watch bands order them if you dare
so there you have it
pretty short list again the thing to
keep in mind is they're make they're not
making this for people with an apple
watch series 5 or even series 4. i think
people with a series 3 or older will
just have this as the new version to
upgrade to around the holiday season
conveniently but the truth is most
people don't even need this newest
version with all the bells and whistles
and extra sensors there's also the new
apple watch se which has the new s6 chip
but hey there's no electrocardiogram and
there's no blood oxygen sensor and
there's no always on display but it is a
much lower price and that's fine for
most people getting their first apple
watch so if it ain't broke don't fix it
and apple absolutely did not fix
anything that wasn't broken they didn't
change the shape or offer a circular
version or anything like that they
didn't
add qi charging they didn't you know
open up a watch face store for
third-party watch faces they didn't
change anything drastic that wasn't
broken with the apple watch so it's
series six for 2020 conveniently
available for the holidays well played
apple
and that's pretty much it for the review
like i said i'm going back to series
five either way that's been it thanks
for watching and tech tober
rolls on catch you guys very soon in the
next one
peace